bonsoir je tafanel linda merci d'être
avec nous en direct par téléphone sur
rtl france le rythme de la mortalité qui
dépensent maintenant on dépasse
maintenant en suède les 100 personnes
toutes les 24 heures 700 personnes au
total sont mortes en suède c'est
beaucoup pour un pays de 10 millions
d'habitants est ce que les suédois tout
d'abord son inquiet commence à prendre
vraiment la mesure de la crise
colling bonsoir oui surtout accuse je
pense que je dois conserver le système
concernait que le gouvernement à lille
suédois tant que je puisse le dire font
confiance au gouvernement et les
autorités sanitaires alors il n'empêche
effectivement les chiffres ne sont pas
très bons alors certains
épidémiologistes suédois défendre le
bilan de la suède
on rappelle qui est à contre-courant pas
de mesures de confinement école ouverte
même si on appelle évidemment respecter
les gestes barrière est ce qu'on ne peut
pas dire quand même aujourd'hui que
c'est une stratégie qui montre ses
limites
je ne suis pas épidémiologistes donc je
ne veux pas m'exprimer sur la pertinence
de certaines mesures
ce que je sais c'est une situation
vraiment innover pour tous les pays et
chacun fait des expériences se trouvent
les mesures pertinentes
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que en europe et
dans le monde avec un plus de nombreux
pays ont adopté des mesures très
strictes les droits politiques
les libertés civiques la liberté de tous
leurs citoyens
citoyens demandent que d'efforts
dirigeants l'essor de cette crise c'est
une tendance très importante pour moi me
rappelle ce que l'on a vu dans les
années 1940
de plus sans conséquences de ces mesures
nous allons avoir des dizaines de
millions de personnes en europe et dans
le monde qui vont perdre leur emploi
leurs revenus à leur assurance santé
cela va avoir des conséquences ça va
aussi coûter des vies donc il s'agit
également de sauver des vies et de
sauver l'avenir politique
vous êtes effectivement raccord avec les
choix de en tout cas des autorités
suédoises
ça veut dire qu'en gros c'est peut-être
pire de stopper totalement une économie
qu'on tue autant peut-être avec une amy
une économie totalement à plat que ne le
fait le virus c'est en résumé votre
propos il ya effectivement non ce que je
veux dire c'est que nous ne savons pas
mais nous savons que la dépression et le
chômage de masse ont des conséquences
sociales ont un coût humain on ne savons
pas combien il va y avoir de mort et
c'est très grave et il faut absolument
étudié l'équilibré trouvé au machrek je
ne critique pas les mesures adoptées ont
suggéré par les écologistes en suède ou
en france
chaque pièce est unique et doit gérer la
crise en fonction de ses
caractéristiques d'une tradition culture
mais pacifique
je pense que la stratégie en suède a
montré de bons résultats je ne suis pas
un expert
cependant ce qui m'importe c'est que en
on voit l'apparition d'une dictature et
elle apparaîtra également dans d'autres
endroits dans le monde la dictature a
des effets très néfastes sur le monde
sur les vilaines sur les familles
so to safe aux causes
nous devons rester concentrés même pas
seulement sur la lutte contre l'hôpital
mais également sur les conséquences que
pourrait être homme impliqué par
certains et les mesures doivent être
pérennes nature à bhl je ne sais pas
combien de temps en france on acceptera
d'être confiné oui je sais la montagne
où il ya beaucoup de tension courroye
ami également des tensions commencent à
apparaître
quelles que soient les mesures adoptées
ne devons plus rester conscients du fait
que nous sommes des démocraties libre et
qu'il faut nous défendre stéphane bern
est ce que vous iriez jusqu'à estimer
que certains gouvernements se
serviraient peut-être de cette crise
sanitaire pour voilà aller vers une
restriction des libertés individuelles
vous parliez de dictature hongrie vous
pensez qu'il ya parfois une arrière
pensée de la part de certains
gouvernements de profiter entre
guillemets de la situation au delà ça
m'a plu oui on va nous avons déjà pu le
constater par exemple effectivement cela
ne fait aucun doute même si vous ou moi
ou quelqu'un qui nous écoutent
souhaitait devenir dictateur dans un
pays soumis démocrate alors cette
pandémie serait tu me grandes occasions
véritable chance ce que loris et de
l'allemagne le des remarques et beaucoup
d'autres pays font c'est une bonne chose
parce que on peut dire eh bien ces
autres pays on monte également confiner
leurs citoyens il ya la police dans les
rues là bas aussi qui empêche les jeunes
de se déplacer en italie
là dans les rues saison que la même
chose cela n'arrivera pas seulement mon
fils cela tend bien d'autres pays en
plus de toutes les morts dues au corps
on a viré ça il aura beaucoup de morts
dus à aux pertes des libertés merci
beaucoup je t' as fan aline berthe
professeur en sciences politiques à
l'université de göteborg d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france nous avoir
apporté votre point de vue